[Musica]
[Applauso]
sin da piccolo ma osservando il mondo mi
sono accorto che esistono due grandi
categorie psicologiche
pensate un po cosa pensavo quando ero
piccolo sì insomma due grandi categorie
psicologico oppure se preferite due
grandi recipienti due enormi recipienti
entro cui è possibile inscrivere
l'intera genere umano la prima grande
categoria è quella dei cuori secchi sì
ovviamente non esiste in italiano questa
parola ma la sono inventata per me un
cuore secco è un cinico un'indifferente
è uno che letteralmente c'è il cuore
secco è uno che c'è una piccola zona di
terra arida al posto del cuore è
comunque re secco per intenderci è uno
di quelli che credono in mors tua vita
mea
uno di quelli che credono che la vita
consistenti affari superficiali il sesso
gratuito
il successo a discapito degli altri il
denaro una personaggio
ecco io però mi sono accorto che i quali
secchi non soffrono sì ecco in realtà
non sono nemmeno troppo contenti proprio
perché hanno un cuore secco però non
soffrono ecco la seconda categoria
entro cui è inscrivibile il genere umano
è quello dei cuori bomba per me un cuore
bomba è un debole gentile è un fragile
forte è uno che al posto del cuore c'è
una bomba pronto ad implodere ad
esplodere al primo impulso se l'impulso
positivo allora vive la gioia se
l'impulso invece negativo allora conosce
la depressione lo scoramento la
malinconia cuori secchi fuori bomba per
me il mondo e questa roba qua si
chiamatemi pure maniche e ho esagerato
semplicista ma io credo veramente in
questa divisione
dunque la cattiva notizia è che i cuori
secchi
la bella notizia invece è che non sempre
i cuori secchi si sono pietrificati
vi racconto una storia viva dunque c'è
una scuola una scuola per poveri una
scuola per reietti una scuola di
periferia ecco una di quelle scuole in
cui mai e poi mai vorremmo mandare i
nostri figli a studiare una di quelle
scuole che so in cui gli insegnanti
farebbero carte false pur di ottenere il
trasferimento riuscita immaginarla
dunque all'interno ci sono i muri
crepati e neon mezzo scassati
all'esterno ci sono le scritte volgari e
con la bomboletta all'ingresso
sull'ingresso svetta un'insegna
terribile in plastica con questi
acronimi difficilino dss istituto di
istruzione superiore secondaria oppure
i.so e sgs riuscite a vederla
ecco all'interno di questo istituto
all'interno di questa scuola ci sono due
indirizzi
il primo è quello di meccanica al cui
interno studiano soltanto alunni maschi
il secondo indirizza invece quello per
parrucchieri in cui studiano perdonatemi
la semplificazione in cui furono
soltanto o studentesse femmine oppure
gay
ecco all'interno della classe di
meccanica ci sono soltanto student acci
studenti difficili studenti con
un'espressione per aspera ad operare
un'espressione cara alla scuola studenti
da attenzionare cosa poi voglia dire
studenti di attenzionare un altro paio
di maniche
insomma si studenti difficili quindi ci
troviamo l'analfabeta l'orfano
l'immigrato che non parla italiano
i rom che non viene riconosciuto dagli
altri compagni ma su tutti svetta lui il
più cattivo
il più cinico e più violento il più
cuore secco antonio ve lo presento
diciottenne pluribocciato un metro e
novanta per cento chili uno dei capi
ultrà della squadra locale un cappellino
che non toglie nemmeno a lezioni di
fronte ai professori perché lui è un
provocatore un duro e poi un giubbottino
attillato translucido e poi uno zaino su
cui ha disegnato questa svastica per
provocazione non credo che conoscesse il
significato politico uno a settimana
oddio a volte anche uno ogni cinque
giorni altre volte uno ogni dieci giorni
ma la media è un naso rotto a settimana
perché antonio sceglie la propria
vittima lo sbeffeggia lo provoca e poi
se all'uscita quello prova a reagire con
un cazzotto gli scassa il naso perché
tutti devono sapere chi è sempre in
ritardo a scuola sempre sbracato sul
banco ormai un compito fatto insomma a
questo punto il fatto che fumi in bagno
sembra l'ultimo dei problemi
ecco non è evidentemente il cocco di
nessun professore perché è uno che
studia i professori lo guardano con una
certa un po sconsolati no guarda una
certa compassione perché dopotutto cosa
volete che diventi antonio ovviamente un
carcerato nemmeno le compagne lo
vogliono perché porta in viso una
terribile cicatrice che gli sfigura il
volto
nemmeno gli amici lo vogliono perché è
inaffidabile egoista perchè tradirebbe
tutti per il proprio tornaconto perché è
un cuore ecco un cuore secco che però un
giorno la combina veramente grossa è una
mattina come tutte le altre sono le 11
sono la ricreazione
le porte si aprono gli studenti sono già
pronti tutti a sgattaiolare no c'è chi
va alle macchinette c'è chi va in bagno
eco antonio questa volta no questa volta
punta
alla classe nelle parrucchiere ecco la
porta è aperta
lui entra come se fosse un alunno della
classe si assicura che gli altri lo
guardino perché per fare quello che ha
intenzione di fare è necessario che ci
sia un pubblico è necessario che ci sia
qualcuno pronto a vivere
ecco individua la compagna è messa lì in
prima fila un po esile curva sui libri
che sta ripassando probabilmente per la
materia successiva e allora leva alle
spalle è un certo punto si caccia e
pisano di fuori e glielo sbattere sul
banco come fosse una bandiera
sono attimi di panico si capisce le
compagnie urlano mezza scuola accorre in
classe per intervenire
nessuno sa veramente il coraggio di
allontanare antonio perché è violento
soltanto i bidelli hanno l'ardire di
spingerlo al di fuori della dell'aula
qualcuno giustamente chiama la polizia
ma alcuni un cuore secco antoni un duro
non si spaventa di queste cose anzi e
vai in bagno raggiunge i compagni e con
una certa spocchia comincia a raccontare
quello che ha fatto si era lì mi sono
caccia del pisello di fuori era lungo
duro leale piaciuto con una certa
vanteria raccontato tutto questo è come
se nulla fosse accaduto
si accende una sigaretta e fuma eppure
qualcosa è caduto sì lo si capisce
quando alle 11 e 10 la stessa campanella
e la ricreazione sono alla fine della
ricreazione e nessuno torna in classe
perché è successo qualcosa di veramente
grave perché il criminale deve pagare
tutti vogliono la sua testa
gli stessi compagni le compagne del
colosso del corso di parruccheria gli
stessi professori segretari tutti
vogliono la testa di questo criminale ed
effettivamente la polizia con una certa
solerzia arriva ora voi immaginate
l'impatto dell'arrivo della polizia in
una scuola di periferia
no tutte e tutte in fervore fanno tutti
in fervore no la notizia arriva alla
preside
la preside si precipita all'ingresso si
frappone fra l'ingresso e gli agenti
perché pensate un po la preoccupazione
di un dirigente scolastico perché teme
che ci sia uno scandalo nella sua scuola
e allora frapponendosi fra l'ingresso e
gli agenti sostanzialmente chiede del
tempo per provare a metterci una pezza
ecco per provare a lavare i panni in
casa per provare a convincere quella
luna a chiedere scusa alla compagna ma
come fare
si fa consegnare la lista di tutti i
suoi docenti controlla le date di
nascita sceglie il più giovane lo
sceglie maschio perché per parlare con
quella bestia che li in bagno che sta
fumando come nulla fosse accaduto
serve un maschio e allora individuato
questo docente giovanissimo gli consegna
un fascicolo il fascicolo di antonio ora
non so se voi sapete come funziona e
funziona un fascicolo di un alunno ma è
un faldone al cui interno si trovano
vita morte e miracoli di un alunno
dunque a questo giovane insegnante il
compito di contattare immediatamente i
genitori di antonio che nel frattempo
sono mai visti convincerli a intervenire
è cercare di far rinsavire un po il
figlio e allora questo professore a pare
il fascicolo sul fascicolo praticamente
ci sono le ragnatele perché mai nessuno
lo ha aperto e il fascicolo parla da sé
alunno difficile bocciato tre volte
altrettante volte cacciato dalle scuole
servizi sociali figlio l'isola madre
senza un padre senza un reddito senza un
domicilio
insomma c'è da mettersi le mani ai
capelli però c'è un muro di telefono e
probabilmente il numero di telefono
della madre e allora questo insegnante
prende la cornetta dg del numero il
telefono squilla ma nessuno risponde
primo tentativo a vuoto
secondo tentativo a vuoto eppure sono le
undici eventi perché nessuno risponde
finalmente al terzo tentativo
una voce strappare dal sogno
risponde sì pronto e sono un professore
della scuola di antonio lei e la madre
no non è la madre e la sorella la madre
non si sa dove sia non si sa dove abbia
passato una notte
ok ma lei e la sorella maggiore guardi
la prego venga scuola perché è successo
qualcosa di grave perché antonio oggi
non è in sé no anche questa volta la
risposta è no la sorella maggiore non
può venire non può venire nemmeno la
madre perché si vergognano e perché
chiede l'insegnante la domanda
probabilmente un po naif
ecco non possono venire perché battono
non una ma tutti e due e quindi i
compagni di antonio a scuola le
riconoscerebbero la conversazione a fine
qui e allora arriva la preside chiede
conto di questa chiamata l'insegnante
inventa che in realtà non c'è mai stata
questa chiamata però chiede il permesso
di poter parlare a questo lungo
difficile e lo ottiene e quindi questo
insegnante giovane giovanissimo nemmeno
trent'anni sale del bagno si trovava al
piano di sopra e trova antonio da solo
che fuma e si fa offrire una sigaretta
non parlano in questa fase della
conversazione non parlo fumano e basta
ci andiamo a barranco cene a prendere un
caffè
questi due vanno al bar della scuola
immaginate il clima di sospensione tutti
vedono questi due che stanno andando al
bar alla ticosa mai parleranno ecco e
antonio un po scosso
sembra quasi che a scoppio ritardato
abbia capito la gravità di quello che ha
fatto ma non vuole ramanzine lui è un
cuore secco e quale secchi non chiedono
scusa né si pentono
ma il professore cerca delle vie diverse
quanto hai visto ieri intanto è già due
pali il rigore sbagliato
staimo retrocediamo procediamo sicuro
insomma questi due parlano di tutto
parlano di calcio di max
fine di motori parlano delle cosce di
ilary blasi parlano parlano persino
della preside e per la prima volta un
adulto guarda quel fanciullo lì senza
schemi senza compassione senza
giudicarlo e lo stesso antonio è
spiazzato e perché testo adulto mi sta
parlando così perché non mi rifila
ramanzina che so io cosa rispondere
perché non mi minaccia con la bocciatura
allora vuol dire questo avere un padre
vuol dire questo avere un fratello
maggiore una guida il barista serve i
due caffè antonio lo beve amaro il
professore lo sa ma con lo zucchero
quindi strappa la bustina ficca nella
tazzina gira col cucchiaino lo in gola
tutti in una volta tanto ma tu ce l'hai
una sorella
simone so se domani mi caccia il titolo
di forray e lo sbatte in faccia
tu come reagiresti
ecco in quel momento antonio il cinico
antoni il violento antono il volgare
alto nel cuore secco crolla come in un
interrogatorio e comincia a piangere
come probabilmente il bambino che non è
mai stato come probabilmente nessuno gli
ha mai insegnato a fare e piange realtà
talmente tanto da da mangiare quel suo
insegnante
nonostante sia un maschio e una femmina
ho fatto una cazzata professor la
cazzata era fatta però forse non era del
tutto tardi e allora antonio con le
lacrime ancora gli occhi raggiunge la
compagna le chiede scusa davanti a tutti
così come davanti a tutti l'aveva offesa
ed è molto fortunato perché la compagna
accetta le scuse
probabilmente perché lo vede sincero poi
va in presidenza accetta la punizione
che gli viene comminata una sospensione
di tre giorni e della polizia invece non
ci fu più bisogno perché andrò via
ecco dal giorno dopo antonio fu un
alunno diverso ma il più cattivo
mai più violento mai più stronzo mai più
cuore secco imparò per esempio che a
lezione quando c'era il professore il
cappello bisogna ma toglierlo
poi però lo poteva tenere ma lezione no
e rinuncia pure ad andare in giro con
questo zaino su cui aveva disegnato
questa svastica ecco di propria
spontanea volontà
la cancellata e cominciò a studiare
certo con le sue difficoltà con le sue
lacune coi suoi tempi con suoi ritmi a
studio dignitosamente si diplomò è il
caso
pensate un po ha voluto che è agli esami
di stato in commissione ci fosse proprio
quello stesso insegnante sulla cui
spalla aveva pianto la mattina di un po
di anni prima e quell'insegnante ero io
era il 7 luglio del 2015 è antonio fu
licenziato con 60 centesimi è stato il
60 più bello e più significativo che io
da insegnante abbia mai dato
ecco io non lo so se questa storia
posseggano o meno una morale forse che
sì forse che no forse la morale è che i
quali secchi esistono sì ma che non
sempre hanno il cuore di pietra
dopotutto un cuore secco è un cuore
bomba a cui nessuno ha insegnato l'amore
ciao